so first of all
thank you very much to the organi
organizers to have
invited me to to speak on this
very interesting occasion one question
about my speech since in 20 minutes
we cannot say everything we would like
to say
my presentation will be a little bit
rough as everybody knows
the chinese ambitions in the south china
sea
are based on the nine not only the nine
dashed line
nine tesh then ten dashed line
if we take the this and there the nine
dashed line
uh generally admitted it dates back to
the nine
to 1947. even if some scholars
have found that we can find
the first presentation of this line
around
the 1930-1936 so i'm waiting for some
more details about that if it's possible
but the first you know the the the point
is everybody or a lot of people say
because it has been printed by
official governmental printing
offices this 1947
dashed line is an official line it's not
because it has not been accompanied by
any official claim with this
official claim accompanying a map
such as this one so we had to wait
until the night the 7th of may 2009
to have the first genuine chinese
official claim about this nine dashed
line
so after the
signing of the united nations
convention on the law of the sea that is
an important point
this reaction from the chinese has been
generated
by these claims in 2009
first a common claim between
china and between vietnam and malaysia
in the southern part of this ocean you
see
and the vietnamese claim
of da nong in the north west
part of the south china sea as you
you can see on this map a very
small line which defines
the limits of the 200 nautical
miles of each of the
riparian states coastal
states that's very important that is
what is remaining
as high c
later on the 11th of january 2013
the chinese published this new 10-10
dashed line
with the 10 the tenth dash on the uh
on the east side of taiwan
the nine first dashes were not changed
the philippines noticed that the ten
dashed line is designed
as chinese national boundaries that is
very important
that would mean that all that is inside
this uh
buffalo tong tong as the the south east
asian
nation uh say uh that means that uh it
could be considered by the chinese as a
territorial sea
with all the consequences that can uh
be drawn from there but for the moment
being
no official value for the human being
this claim has not been accompanied by
any official declaration
it's the same when the chinese published
this
vertical map completely
full on the 26th of 2000
2014. there the south china sea
clearly appears as a chinese territorial
sea
and according to an american study
at a high level the design they studied
the the
this representations this drawing colors
thickness
and r of the dots are exactly the same
ones as on the the land border ones
so for the human being scientists
politicians
strategists continue wondering what is
the real meaning
of this 9 10 dash line because the
chinese never delivered
the coordinates of the 10 dashed lines
but to continue in my mind i this
involved only myself to continue
wondering what the nine dashes mean is
in my mind a huge strategic mistake
because the nine dashed line want it or
not
is genuinely there without or with or
without
coordinates we don't care it is there
we cannot avoid this consideration
that clearly shows the chinese ambitions
and the chinese if we don't know what
are the genuine
coordinates of that the chinese do know
where they are and i took the example of
china national oil offshore company
who sent a call for meeting
in on the 23rd of june 2012
for oil foreign companies to enter into
product sharing agreement on nine blocks
that i write on the vietnamese e
e z e e z and if you consider where are
the blocks
they are right on the limit of the nine
dash line nine ten dash line
so our outsiders attitude
because i am an outsider it's just like
the horse
which doesn't want to jump over the
obstacle
to justify the 9 10 dash line chinese
uses a spacious artifice
based on a distorted interpretation of
the enclosed
sorry i have not enough time to explain
that in details
but that's uh according to that to that
china marilina
on the islands rocks and even submarine
elevations
and departing from that mainland
on the waters that these features are
generated
generating to demonstrate that the 910
dash line is the line which
equitably shares the sea between
its alleged maritime territory and the
other
other riparians once
everybody believes that the dispute in
the south china sea
parasails between vietnam and china
mackelsfield bank to russia submarine
elevations both of them
china by china alone scarborough between
china
and the philippines this
three group of submarine elevations
and reefs are gathered into one
into one concept clearly uh described by
professor
john uh power professor joker yuan
and it is called zhang tao no time to
explain that
but if we can go there on this question
a little bit later if you want spread
place between vietnam
china philippines malaysia and brunei
philippines four
fifths of the northern part the the
northern part of the spratleys
fourth four-fifths of the spratleys
called kalayaan
vs china vietnam and malaysia malaysia
on the south vias china vietnam and
philippines
brunei on louisiana reef vs china and
vietnam
indonesia contrary to a lot of people
believe
is not a stakeholder in the territorial
dispute but there is a problem because
the nine dashed line
is crossing over the indonesian east
the problem is there james scholl
and lucania scholar which are under
uh submarine elevation an exception for
luke and i shoulde
that that could draw one problem
uh in in a short time
uh soon so everybody believes
that the the territorial dispute is in
the
south china sea are because
of what the existence of polymetallic
nodules
in the bottom of the sea and as you can
see on the the map
the the the part which is enclosed
inside
the red line is uh
is is fit with the
the high sea the chinese for the moment
being with that
have the possibility not to collect the
nodules
but at least to explore the depths
so if the inter international community
remains silent
over the the claims of china of the
under
almost the whole south china sea china
will confiscate
what is remaining of high sea and that
is completely contrarily
to the preamble and the articles
related to the ic of the enclosed
one problem could be a reason
for the fishery resources could be a
problem for
the chinese claims there
as you can see on the the sketch here
the chinese uh printed then published
this this figure this polygon
on the first of january 2014
and they declared that
departing from this date all foreign
fishers including from southeast asia
must first request the authorization
from china to have the right to fish
there
so that could be a good reason that's
not that's only one stake
the other one could be the hydrocarbon
resources
that could be a good reason so these are
the main hydrocarbon deposits
which are all scattered all along the
metamorphologic metamorphologic
continental chef shelf around the south
china sea
that could be a good reason because the
910 dash line is crossing
all of these deposits
all in the other southeast asian states
eez but that's not that's not the main
reason that's only one
one stake that could be the navigation
and
safety and security so i don't enter
into the detail
of of that but as you can see eighty
percent of the chinese hydrocarbon
procurement are crossing this south
china sea this is a prc
vulnerability vulnerability as well as
japan
and south korea so we can consider that
the chinese would be very happy to be
alone
to exert the security operations over
that area but that's not
the main reason the main reason is this
one the chinese wants to be able to
deploy
it there for ssbns from sanya harbour
up to the depths of the south china sea
and of the pacific ocean
in the best conditions of security you
are going to tell me
in 1947 until a
recent date the ssbns didn't exist
but since now the ssbns exist
that reinforce the pretension of the
the chinese over that sea the problem
is for these ssbns to escape
a hostile air observation to limit the
risks of
submarine spotting and you can see the
area of vulnerability vulnerability for
these
submarines because the four ssbns
gene types they have presently are still
in discrete
easily spottable so this is the main
reason for
what china wants to empty the south
china sea of any foreign naval presence
china wants to sanctuarize the south
china sea
and we come here to miss what mr fels
is told this morning about
the possibility of the application of
the dongtron monroe doctrine
by the chinese on the south china sea
but but trying to empty the sea of any
foreign naval presence
presumed of steel is not enough
it's necessary to prevent the us and its
allies
to enter that sea and there mr fels we
joined
all together how china feels threatened
by the usa by the containment of the usa
reinforcement of the american presence
in japan and south korea
usa maintaining the military support to
taiwan
u.s and philippine mutual defense
agreements reinforced
by the enhanced defense cooperation
agreement
signed in 2015 and declared
in conformity with the philippine
constitution recently by the supreme
court
in 2016 activation of the military
cooperation with vietnam
important political openings towards
india and burma
so the in this condition china is
compelled
to reinforce the defense of its
approaches the south china sea is not
enough to ensure
the chinese overall strategic security
disposition
facing the presumed u.s threat
that was why admiral your watching
in 1974 admiral young
is the reformer of the chinese navy he
wanted to change the chinese navy from a
coastal navy
to a high sea navy
so in 1974 he defined two lines of
forward defense
one grid line of immediate defense
resting on the
uq archipelagos taiwan and the southeast
asian
nations a blue line
which as you can see is resting on the
mariana
chain for that to china
in intent to implement the a
a to ad doctrine with specific means
these are seven nuclear submarines
attack and 48 classical
submarines which can be committed in
saturation against the prison
enemy the development program of
development of aircraft carriers
planned the plan program is for five
carriers
the chinese deny this this that but for
the human being we have a second
aircraft carriers under construction
in shanghai you have you have here are
the figures
the the pictures of the evolution of the
variation
which has become the learning
they have also the development of the
ballistic anti-anti-ship missile
df-21d the range of them
is 2 7 000 is 272
700 kilometers sorry if we take
this hypothesis of firing from the coast
we can see that they can reach normally
if it works
really some targets
inside which have overcrossed this
red line and if you see
if you compare you can see that this red
red line
fit almost with the blue line as defined
by
general admiral york watching the
principle of
work of this is a target designation
through the satellite constellation jet
tianting
you can and once the
heads are on their decent
phase the terminal guidance is by an
overhead
and over the horizon targeting system
this is a sketch of uh bombs arriving
on the an aircraft carrier and the the
planes
which could not could which cannot uh
reach the decks anymore
but a280 has a strategy has limits
it is only offend defensive
and it may be uh sorry
opposed by the us with the
implementation of the earth
battle concept i don't enter into the
detail
we have no time enough on the signing
chinese side a2 a.d is not enough to
reach
the strategy goals aimed at the past in
the pacific ocean
first the global naval expansion but
most of uh above all the being to be
able
to being to be able uh to threat even
rich corners with missiles
if the president julong do to the
the range is for the women being 8 000
kilometers
the first public appearance occurred on
may
2009 with these pictures
provided by cctv so if
that this missile is i'm sorry
is fired from the south china sea it can
only reach the northern part
of the hawaii archipelago that's the
reason why the
genes the chinese submarine jeans must
be able
to exit the south china sea but
in this case they are
prisoners of crossing the
the bashi channel which which is
situated
in the south of taiwan and in the north
of the philippine island of
luzon so the dream for the chinese
is to blow up the taiwanese bolt because
the taiwanese bolt
as you can see is locking
the uq archipelagos and the southeast
asian countries archipelagos
like this blowing up the taiwanese bolt
would provide the plan with waters
entirely chinese so as to sail freely
either by the south of taiwan for the
ssbns
that explains why the chinese the the
chinese maneuvers
of sanctuary region of the south china
sea
or by the north and that explains the
settlement
of an a d i z air defense and
i def identification zone in the
east east china sea the hardening of the
dispute of
over the senkaku islands and even the
simmering of the chinese claims
over their uq that would uh
blowing up the the the the
taiwanese bolt would allow the jin
submarines
to try to position themselves close to
the certain line
of defense presently under consideration
and we can consider it as forward decent
defense from where some towns of western
america could be reached
that would compel the u.s to try to
forbid the approach
of this line the scheme will be
different with the next generation of
ssbns and geelong three missiles with
three possible
possible versions will be operational
to conclude for me and i
joined also mr feltz about this chinese
irredentism
in south china sea has totally
essentially become bound
to a standoff with the usa today
china is not is not really are not
really the winners
but strong troublemakers because of
their inopportune activities in the
south china sea
reclamation of eight features in the
sprite lanes armament of the paracels
with anti-aircraft missiles
cruise missiles and so on reclamation
project we have to
to pay attention to that reclamation
point project
over scarborough reef as in as let's
practice
and that brings the intensification of
the un's naval
presence of the u.s military relations
and cooperation with the south china
south
east asian nations singapore traditional
but also philippine and vietnam
and of the interests of japan india
australia
and even south china south carolina for
that sea thank you very much for
listening to me
you